people say Reese's or Reese's when I say
Reese's they're like you mean Reese's no
I mean Reese's all right relax chill out
what's up guys it's Caleb McLaughlin and
these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
Jolly Rancher
but the blue raspberry
I know a lot of people love blue
raspberry blue raspberry I want to blame
him I just don't know what it is like
have you ever had like blue raspberry in
the summer and it's like hot outside you
got like a cold drink maybe even just
like a Sprite or something and you drink
it and have this in your mouth
man
it's it's like heaven bro you just
so I'm not gonna put this in my mouth
because my tongue is going to be blue
I'll just lick it really fast it's like
a
um I'll have it after this I'm gonna
take this home with me
in the next one
see M M's peanuts not like skinny little
tiny ones just like the like the round
like
I was about to say the thick ones yeah
the thick ones right put it on the side
peanuts and chocolate that combination
that conjunction is amazing it's just I
was about to say something wild but I'm
not gonna say it because that was how
crazy now we're dying to know what you
were gonna say I'm not saying it I do
not want to be a meme whoa
[Music]
ah
seaweed's nice
I was introduced to this on set filming
stranger things actually I would
actually share this with Sadie senko
plays my co-star we always would like
try to figure out healthy things to eat
we found this on set and when I was
younger I used to be like ew seaweed
chips it's nasty but it's actually
pretty good it's like
has like a salty taste but I used to
think food was just survival I just need
to eat food so I can live
there's the case the zombie apocalypse
comes
I'm training for it that's why I'm
staying in shape
what I do look forward to is like late
night like snacks gay and I would share
like bowling that was a seaweed that
almost came I think it did come out I'm
not sure if it was on camera but we'll
see when it comes out
gay and I would share like full-on
chicken quesadillas together we're on
set for a long night I loved like 2 A.M
like catering like pizza or Domino's or
just being outside and they'll just make
cooking on the grill and it's like the
fire and the smoke at a late night of
like a stranger things set is always
dope and then they will play 80s music
and everyone will be dancing or some
people would be sleeping it really feels
like a camp out
horrible Cherry gummies like I love the
texture very tasty but um
[Music]
it actually was like 2 A.M you know I
finally we were just walking down the
street we went to the corner store we
were just getting a bunch of snacks to
go back to the hotel and just chill
sometimes gummy bears are hit or miss
this always hits my this new movie
coming out shooting stars during Second
only on peacock and what I had to do to
get in shave was just to eat good and
work out condition push-ups all that but
um if you're eating candy and junk food
you get fatigued faster you don't have
the energy to you know execute the
performance so that's the only reason
why I didn't eat much candy but I try to
sink in it once in a while
pretzel yeah I love me some pretzels bro
I have a love and hate relationship with
pretzels you know why because when I was
in school my third grade teacher always
eat pretzels but just be like teaching
the class like so yeah
and it should be like this bro this one
and she would make it look so good I
kept asking her every single day can I
have a pretzel she said no lunch is in
three hours I'm like bro you have it
every day you have a whole bag
come on but then every time I go to
lunch I'll get me some pretzels
hopefully I get a pretzel endorsement
grapes I would say this is definitely
like my very favorite snack because I
love the way it
[Music]
was about to say no something else crazy
not gonna say it but it's just a good
texture I love like a juicy grape yeah
these are good
the juices are flowing
aluminum
it's a healthy snack too so I can eat it
all the time you know I can't eat Jolly
Ranchers in Cherry gummies and stuff I
can have this all the time playing video
games I usually have this sometimes with
like a bowl of green salad just eat it
with my hands
like a wreck a rabbit but rabbits don't
have hands but you know you know what
I'm trying to say
people say Reese's or Reese's I I hate
people that'll be like Reese's like
you're annoying shut up you know what
I'm trying to say when I say Reese's
like you mean Reese's no I mean Reese's
all right relax chill out like I said
chocolate and peanut butter is always a
good combo I don't know what it is
whoever decided like peanut butter and
chocolate would go good together is a
genius
um
[Music]
thank you all for watching me it's Caleb
here make sure you guys check out
shooting stars only on peacock peace
[Music]